this is one of the roads less traveled
on the path to higher education and
that's because it's had to be in this
country we have been in bond as longer
than we have been free southern
university like the other 100
historically black colleges and
universities in the US was born out of
necessity HBCUs like this one were
created to serve the african-american
community these institutions across
America were built to teach the free
children of slaves from the time that
they were founded HBCUs were dedicated
to helping these students succeed
combined HBCUs have more than 1 million
students enrolled but in an integrated
educational system what place do they
have other institutions don't have to
justify their existence in the same way
on a day to day basis that HBCUs they
have to we should be in the position
though everyone in DC's our benefit and
that access
why hey fam I'm you Mayans this is aj+
and this Sunday we've traveled to an
HBCU to talk about their history their
relevancy and what's next for these
educational institutions
[Music]
today I'm in the middle of the more than
6,000 students on southern University's
campus in Baton Rouge Louisiana and the
vast majority of them are blacks it's a
scene that used to be unimaginable
because access to higher education was
certainly non-existent for black people
in the US before historically black
colleges and universities also known as
HBCUs Congress officially defines an
HBCU as a school established before 1964
whose principal mission was and is the
education of black Americans and unlike
what education secretary Betsy DeVos has
said these schools didn't start as
pioneers for school choice let's be
clear there was no choice HBCUs became
prevalent after the Civil War and they
were dedicated to meeting the needs of
the newly freed African American
population Southern University was one
of those schools in the nation's first
black governor PBS Pinchback founded it
in 1880 like the majority of HBCUs
southern university is located in the
southeastern United States why is this
your favorite spot on campus it's so
peaceful like look at the waters and the
waters are so calm and so beautiful
it wasn't the location that drew
eighteen-year-old mckerrod Dixon to
choose this HBCU I feel like I'm here
and I fit in here it doesn't make me
feel so alone while I'm here Dixon was a
star student in her high school she had
the highest SAT score in her class and
she ranked number seven she already had
financial aid packages from two schools
and was looking at attending the
predominantly white University of
Alabama but her plans changed after she
visited its campus at HBCU and Southern
University was not your first choice
what was your first choice my first
choice was the University of Alabama and
why aren't you at the University of
Alabama why aren't we there having this
conversation when I actually went there
on the campus I felt nothing
when I actually visited Southern's
campus it was like this could be not
just my school but this is my home and
that's that will build the the
determining factor for night kira
choosing an HBCU meant surrounding
herself with what she defines as black
excellence when you're at an HBCU and
it's full of black excellence and it's
black pride and everything else it's
almost like you're not just one person
who did it who's done it it's a group of
people who we're doing it and this
atmosphere is what nikiro was talking
about and research shows it has a very
real impact on students some call it the
HBCU effect black HBCU graduates are
twice as likely to be satisfied in their
work have greater community involvement
and they even vote more frequently
according to Bryan bridges of the United
Negro College Fund HBCUs provides
support to the students who needed the
most even though they have the least
amount of resources to help those to
succeed the vast majority of HBCU
enrollees are low-income students and at
some schools they make up nearly the
entire student body Bridges says that
these schools are the largest provider
of scholarships to minority students in
70% of all HBCU undergraduates received
financially need-based Pell grants and
the price tag for HBCUs are 27 percent
lower than their non HBCU counterparts
and yet in 2012 HBCU bachelor degree
recipients borrowed nearly twice the
amount as their non HBCU peers basically
HBCU students are taking out much more
debt to attend less expensive schools
than other students but that hasn't
limited the success of HBCUs even though
they disproportionately enroll
low-income first-generation and
academically unprepared students HBCUs
are unique in their ability to graduate
low-income kids and that's why some have
anxiety about these schools ongoing
financial struggles historically HBCUs
have been underfunded add that to the
fact that the size of their endowments
is one-eighth the size of historically
white colleges and universities for
example Southern University has 13
million in endowments compared that with
the 500 million LSU
a predominantly white University just 11
miles away
Louisiana used to give southern 60% of
the schools funding and now that's
dropped to 20% because the state spent
the last decade slashing funding to
higher education 7 University Vice
Chancellor Michael sub without suggest
these schools need to target a wider
audience and of all their business plans
I believe the HBCUs miss not necessarily
should just focus on african-americans
if we're saying we're about you know
global excellence that means we're about
global engagement because at the end of
the day if we can define ourselves not
just about being about all one
particular population I think we win
HBCUs aren't just competing against one
another for black students they're also
competing against predominately white
institutions or PWI Southern University
has seen a decrease in enrollment
meanwhile LSU's black enrollment rate
has increased from nearly 9% in 2007 to
almost 12% in the 2015-2016 school year
so HBCUs like Southern University are
going to succeed some officials say they
need a better marketing plan and all you
have to do to understand what they mean
is look around
LSU paraphernalia is prominently
displayed everywhere Southern University
not so much one of the things we can
stay at least on the marketing side we
have a market those programs that we
believe can attract people where they
know they can have a job at another day
so in such a competitive market for
students what is the future of HBCUs
we just spent all day telling you about
HBCUs their history their legacy what's
next
let us know what you want us to cover
next what you think of a species and
watch me dance tonight in this room like
share subscribe thanks for watching
[Music]